hi i'm jay cohen author of the cookbook
jewish and this is pro tips from pro
chefs
[Music]
so when it comes to entertaining i'm a
big believer in an oven set to 450
degrees it's your best friend you could
have three racks each with a different
sheet pan and that is the best
temperature for roasting vegetables you
spatchcock your chicken it comes out
super delicious crispy and quick and
really everything can hit the table at
the same time which is always the goal i
handle all the food my husband does all
of the youtube table napkin folding tips
and does all the setting but i'm really
not the expert chef but i do think like
a nice table setting can make a really
big difference so we've gotten really
nice crystal candles like i'll go online
and look up creative napkin folds and
all those little details really add up
and make for a great experience
[Music]
when i'm feeling lazy i
love a good napkin ring and you can
literally just pick up a napkin from the
center and pull it through the ring and
it makes this like beautiful design and
it's also super easy so if i'm in a rush
i just do that i am too lazy to like
press my napkins or iron them so like
some of the folds need need that level
of like no one has time for that nobody
has time for that but another fold i
really like is there are folds where you
can basically create inserts for your
silverware so kind of doubles is like a
napkin fold and also a place for you to
put silverware and arrange it really in
a pretty way and fold it tuck it into
the napkin
[Music]
the key part when it comes to
entertaining is delegating like don't
don't feel like you have to take on this
full burden yourself i'm very lucky that
i have an incredible husband who handles
the the
non-cooking element but feel free to get
your guests involved give them a dish to
bring have them help you out when it
comes to setting up your table really
like
nothing is off limits we really are a
team in that sense in that like usually
as guests are coming in jake is still
prepping in the kitchen so i'm like you
know starting to talk to the guests and
getting them seated at the table and
then you know i'm not helping with the
cooking but as you know plates need to
be cleaned up you know then we switch
roles so jake will sit down and be the
entertainer and i'm like picking up
plates and getting sort of sneaking
things into the dishwasher or cleaning
things in in a subtle way so it
minimizes the workload after the guests
leave
if you want more tips you can head to
the drewbarrymore drewbarrymoreshow.com
pro tips be sure to tag me in anything
you do i'm at j cohen and use the
drew barrymore show
[Music]
you